studios are we thinking whether  theatrical releases are worth it make  the case right now for the big silver  when a movie comes out that you're  interested enough to see  and  it makes you leave your house  and buy a ticket and you could do  anything in the world you want that  night but you decide to go to see a film  one film particular and you go to see it  and maybe you're on your own maybe it's  in the afternoon or maybe it's with your  date or your wife or whoever and you go  and see it and you buy a ticket and you  sit down and you have an experience and  you have an experience with a bunch of  strangers and at that moment once the  movie gets going once the lights are  down  you become a collective and when you  have a good experience it's not always a  good experience but when you have a good  experience those are the things that  stay in your mind and that you remember  for the rest of your life and they  become indelible  indelible snapshots  okay i'll go to the movies